players who you know just uh follow what
other players do but jordan's more of a
creator he's more of a unique thinker he
comes out with ideas and that's why he's
been part of magnus's world
championships team so yeah let's see
what he's got here is we see the queen's
gambit declined
and uh yeah the queen's camera declined
black not taking the baits we do see
um one of the most trendy variations of
this system uh the tarash variation of
the queen's camera declined
and okay what will magnus play here
brings out his bishop this opening has
been very popular uh by
team magnus players that means magnus
cast himself daniel dubov jordan van
furies people that magnus has worked
together with
in world championship training camps and
okay we see maybe a rarer line not the
most uh common over the last few turns
but the kind of whole nature of the
position revolves around black's pawn in
the middle of the board which is an
isolated pawn if that's a strength then
black is doing great if it's a weakness
a target for white then magnus will be
happy
and remember if you yourself want to
become an expert on the queen's gambit
decline this super popular opening on
the tour then we do have that chessable
course by alex kolovich and if you do
join in our question of today we're
asking um what you struggle with the
most in the opening you can win
this course valued at
dollars so please join in and tweet your
answers using the hashtag chesschamps
well they're playing fast obviously
they're uh they're well known in this
opening yep they've probably discussed
either this line or at least something
very similar before they are good
friends they've worked together many
times now um over the last
six months
one year so
nothing new for them maybe but who do
you think this position will favor in
terms of style
uh simon i mean i'd say white uh in
general it depends if black can get any
activity but um it is it's really about
the center of the board and that pawn
the isolated pawn and
magnus loves
slowly maneuvering around a slight
weakness and i would have thought here
that that you know the question is you
know he can do that i don't know if
black can get enough activity i mean he
might even be able to take the knight
take the pawn now but that it looks a
bit risky and i don't think he'll do
that but
i i would have thought magnus would be
comfortable in this position yeah i
think so magnus slightly frowning uh
just to show you mentioned a couple of
captures there simon
big decision this bishop under threat
and uh the natural move would be to step
back just maintain this pin maintain
this tension not commit but uh you also
mentioned simon taking this knight and
then taking the pawn looks greedy
especially while white's king is in the
center but if you can get away with it
it's just gonna be a clear pawn up
um what does black do if you take this
pawn with black then you have to really
be careful of knight checks at some
point um and he's going for it
real attention already um if the queen
doesn't go and take this pawn if you
remove the knight from the board then
suddenly
i mean this bishop is under attack and
uh white's just a clear pawn up now wow
i think bishop before checking the check
might be some way to at least stop white
from castling because black needs to get
some kind of compensation and we and we
know that uh jordan does quite a lot of
rather speculative or aggressive ideas
just to stop his opponent castling he's
done this before the magnus to hold the
draw i think in the last one when he
needs to get draw so maybe there's some
compensation here for example if black
castles yes blacks upon down but white's
king is kind of getting in the way of
the two rooks uh they can't connect
anytime soon yeah and the black rogues
can centralize so
yeah put them on the open lines but the
fact that jordan is paused after this
last move bishop takes knight the fact
that he's even considering wrecking his
own pawn structure no no no no no no you
can't do that not against not against
anyone yeah i mean these are too ugly
these isolated fawns here
gives me the shivers
um and normally jordan he's the type of
guy yes he's got full uh he's full of
opening ideas but if he knows an idea
he'll play it instantly
he doesn't want to sit around and bluff
and kind of play mind games
and big question does magnus take or
does he not yeah it would also be viable
to just castle the king away to safety
first well i mean one thing i've seen
magnus do a lot more in the last tour
even though the tour maybe wasn't that
successful was for him was take some of
these risky looking pawns he was very
brave capturing a pawn which i hadn't
really seen him do as much before so i
don't know i mean ivanka is he gonna is
he gonna grab that one in the middle
here or is he gonna
you know it kind of feels like he should
have been i don't think i would i think
i'd be too scared i think i'd just
castle here i mean like you know
watching favors the brave simon
if you can calculate your way out of
trouble
which you know these strong players love
to do yeah they do i'd just be too
scared i'd be like nah i know i see a
check i've got to move my king don't
like it castle if you don't say that
sacrificing points and attacking you
don't want to be the one grabbing and
defending yeah that's maybe a personal
thing which is a bit of a mistake but um
i think you're probably right and he has
he has he's taken it right okay there we
go yeah yeah yeah he's calculated so
there's absolutely no trouble and i i
think this is maybe the correct kind of
continuation after capturing the night
you know you kind of go all in at the
minute
and
whilst jordan is thinking about what to
do well
i do feel i love this quiz of the day
that we have where we're asking what are
the things you most struggle with in the
opening because it really feels like you
know it's kind of a problem clinic that
we can help with like almost like an
agony column and uh sri says they
struggle to keep patience in openings
which is uh something grandmaster david
howell is incredibly patient not not
just in the opening i feel as well so
incredibly boring i am no no no no no no
no no patience the patient is a virtue
as they say i mean you don't always need
to be patient in openings i think if
if you're feeling that you're impatient
in openings then maybe you're just
playing the wrong openings maybe you
should be choosing openings where you
can be a bit more direct um so that's
one to one to check out yeah
make sure you choose openings where it
does suit your suit your instincts good
advice david and bonaventure james says
that they start to feel flustered by
aggressive openings that they are not
familiar with putting themselves this
then results in them putting themselves
in a very bad position by playing
reactively and that's something that i
can relate to actually especially when
i'm faced with outright aggression and
with someone who i know is famous for
playing in a
creative aggressive style and
has a higher rating than me that's those
are the two kind of kind of conditions
where i feel flustered if it's someone
lower rated than me i tend to go well
come on
i have studied the caricom for years
come and get me if you have a if you
think you're hard enough i
actually honestly think if you're
thinking you're hard enough
i do i do you know shot yeah
it's totally i don't know it's totally
inappropriate but anyway that's what i
think but i can definitely relate to
that feeling of feeling flustered and
maybe feeling out prepared
i think the kind of key is just to have
a belief in your openings and belief in
your ability
to resolve those problems and i think a
good kind of thing is to always think
back to the times that you did solve
those problems before and you reacted in
a positive way
and just take inspiration from that and
uh also i would kind of suggest taking a
look at the concrete problems on the
board i mean
if the position is dangerous then okay
look after your king
and uh here we go it's getting very
short it's getting sharp crazy stuff on
the board
yep i mean i've been white
i don't know both
white castling me this looks so logical
and uh
you know who's whose king is weaker now
black's king surely black's king's in
the center white's king is safely tucked
away i don't like this of black just
just instinctively just looks like
something wrong for black here yeah i
mean unless you can somehow trade the
queens off where black maybe will be
fine
i think magnus is going to win a
miniature i just have a feeling he's
going to win quite a quick game here
just jordan we mentioned the porn
sacrifice he's known for those he's
carefree he's creative he's ambitious
but
the fact that he paused for two or three
minutes that's very unlike him he's very
uncharacteristic but also
i mean he normally loves having a safer
king
and white is the one creating threats
white's knight now is attacking the
black rook in the corner is kind of
attacking white uh the black light
squared bishop
i mean if you trade that one off even if
it's opposite color bishops that favors
the side who's attacking the side with
the safer king
yeah i don't like it
and white's queen has a nice square
over on the side of the board as well
where where it increases the pressure a
little bit
so just
instinctively this looks horrible for
black i mean white's got everything you
want surely and i expect the queen will
move there now so if the queen moves
three squares uh it can even swing to
the other side of the board it attacks
the knight i mean we could maybe show
that and it's attacked so why not as you
mentioned
here
you're kind of helping this uh pressure
against the knight
and the swinging you mentioned happens
uh from this angle you can swing the
whole way over and start checking the
black king um i mean you've got a choice
of squares maybe this one maybe this one
on the edge of the board
i mean i i dread to think how black is
going to survive this one with this king
in the middle black isn't even a pawn up
so you're suffering for nothing really
um at least if you're suffering or
defending you want to have an extra pawn
or want to have some long-term
positional compensation but
yeah i mean i i don't see it
it's just i don't know what the way my
brain works somehow but i was just
thinking about that football charm which
you were saying like come and have a go
if you think you're hard enough yeah
there must be some good chess chance
that people think of you know so maybe
we can ask that to the audience what
what is the best sort of chant like
mantra you can get into your head when
is it is it come and never go if you
think you're hard enough i'll take you
down you gambit or take everything or is
there something is it water yeah what's
your motto david
is it like patience is a virtue my
friend or is it i'm going to make them
suffer
i'm enjoying myself something about this
give me a hundred moves and i'll be your
i can remember when you have simon
because uh we went to the good night
during the oslo esports cup and you
played with the great ajalen in the
chess 24 company you played uh it must
been a blitz or maybe even a bullet game
oh right bullet game i feel like you
guys were bantering back and forth so
much and then you were winning the game
and you were you were yelling at what is
this what is this what is this
it's checkmate on the ball
it was fantastic i
may have been a little bit drunk
shall we say
and that was the video
oh dear oh
dear but i think i i was getting given
as good as i got i think
i think i think it was i think
it was fun
i vaguely remember that on the board
i remember that he played a great game
checkmated the king of the g-files
yeah it's on the cab i'm sure it's all
right down the good night
after the last round of the of the major
cup so i think that's the key with trash
talk you only give trash talk to people
who give it back yep oh and
she was trash
yeah i was getting a lot myself so i
mean you wouldn't just pick on an
eight-year-old kid and start doing that
so come on what the hell is that like
you know
so but what what's magnus doing yeah i'm
sorry
you know keep the queens on the board i
mean the the general rule is if your
king is safer than your opponent's king
white's king is safe from the black king
keep the queens on the board i mean this
can't be a bad move but it is safety
first right yes definitely not a bad
move we should clarify so we can't be
too critical
magnus still has the advantage if queens
come off for example okay magnus
frowning there but uh if black's queen
takes the white queen then one of the
white rooks will recapture and white
gains time we're gonna see it happen on
the board white's rook now will attack
the black bishop in front of it black's
knight is well a bit unstable we're
going to see a lot of trades and magnus
who's going to grind away in the end
game maybe magnus will even win one pawn
in the process so he's chosen a safety
first approach as you mentioned simon
but
why win one pawn when you can go for
checkmate and uh i guess it's more his
style and maybe he's thinking about
jordan's style and he's thinking well
jordan's a very creative player he likes
complex positions so he's playing with
his style and against his opponent's
style so it does actually make some
sense safe advantage rather than a
complicated one this is the type of move
that i would approach that i would take
against a great attacker like yourself
even like jordan but um also if i was
playing someone i was a bit scared of um
do you guess that's why i can't believe
you don't get scared when you play me i
know that
but i mean i don't know high-rated
players i think it's natural human play
it's kind of human nature i mean if i
play magnus
boy it's terrifying
even if i know i'm winning um we
actually played a blitz game down at the
good night recently kyle was watching
and
i actually had checkmate in three moves
on the board but he was trash talking me
and i was like oh no i just assumed i
wasn't winning and of course i didn't
but too much confidence in him yeah
exactly so um yeah that's why i'm
slightly surprised because magnus is
normally the one full of confidence and
to play the safety first approach like
you say there's some logic behind it
there's a lot of
it's kind of nice to take all the risk
out trading all the queens but
um less possible reward comes along with
the less risk
so okay jordan can he defend this end
game black's bishop needs to move
but where to the black dot squared
bishop that is the question and uh
whilst jordan is pausing for thought
well we also have a selfie competition
where we have a fantastic prize of
chessable goodies up for grabs all
signed by the great anish giri
and goldeneye 187 is saying they are
student of the game and they're watching
chess ball
masters and cheers to everyone also
cheers to you back absolutely there you
go
and uh guru of mukichi is supporting the
whole event and enjoying the games and
is giving us a big thank you from india
i love it when they when everyone tells
us where they're watching the show from
because it just shows how global
everything is and uh lanadon is uh
sending us greetings from the swiss alps
in the to the chess champs studio and
it's a rooting for a niche and yeah of
course we get a picture of the beautiful
swiss landscape and
wow
well we have to go back to the board
because we were kind of talking about
the king
the bishop
defending retreating but we never
thought about the king and look at
magnus's face he's just i mean a moment
ago he was just frowning
i don't understand i i mean i vaguely
saw this but i just assumed dwight was
winning a piece what is jordan's idea
after this capture black simply has to
take back this night now with his pawn
now white is going to give a check
with his rook the black king is going to
get forced away from the defense of his
bishop i think he's got a sneaky idea in
mind of double attacking a couple of
things later but
we uh should we jump in we're about to
see this on the board
maybe we can keep an eye on the players
because we might see some big reactions
on there uh on their faces and uh let's
just show what happened black's king
came forward we were expecting uh due to
this attack the bishop to move for
example to retreat um a couple of safe
squares there maybe go to the edge of
the board but instead black's king came
forward as a defender defending this
bishop now after a trade we can see
magnus potentially checking the black
king and when the king retreats we can
see a simple trade of rooks and now
taking this black bishop off the board
and black's idea must be surely to bring
the king to this square attacking the
white rook and attacking the bishop
at first i thought maybe you just give
up the rook you take this knight off and
then you retreat your bishop to a safe
square to stop the black rook coming in
with any checks maybe this one isn't so
clear because black does have a past
pawn black has a very active king so
maybe this is what jordan wants but uh
i did take a peek and actually there is
a winning move oh not swing the rook all
the way to the h5 square you called it
this is maybe what jordan has missed you
can bring the white rook across and
defend from afar
and actually this is the only safe
square on this rank on the fifth rank uh
to defend the bishop and the thing is if
the pawn attacks a rook sorry dave
the thing is if there's a check the
bishop can actually block and run away
to safety so this is completely fine for
white white has an extra bishop and as
simon mentions the pawn can step forward
attacking the white rook but i guess you
just move out there away you just take
this pawn and after your bishop falls
you just push create a safe square for
your king and uh you're just a pawn up
with white and
more to come
this is the position on the board we're
expecting magnus to just swing his rook
across and
most likely win the game and yeah we
didn't look at those stats for the
queen's gambit declined the opening they
played in this game and it was you know
it was nice for white uh the score was
what like 59
it's
56.75
and 40
43.8
for black
um but there were a lot of games played
and i don't think they are too bad just
statistics for black for black but here
you know can we blame the opening in
this particular example i'm not sure
i think in chess in general i think most
openings have roughly 55 for white
um that's just because you start with
the first move and that's if you look at
the whole kind of sample size where
maybe at the lower levels having white
is more of an advantage
i mean at the top level people are so
well prepared with black nowadays that i
think that
that gap is closing but we will reveal
start revealing throughout the
tournament the most successful openings
both were white and for black throughout
the tournament and you have the list in
front of me and there are a couple black
uh
where black is in the lead and score
against white and a few openings
guess what they are yeah interesting
it's hard to say right i reckon sicilian
is going to be up there do you think so
for white for black so we've got to
guess
yeah because usually because kya said
there are some openings where the black
black pieces are in the lead
maybe there might be
this is on the tour this is all the tour
oh
we'll start revealing all of it tomorrow
friendships maybe french defense yeah
and uh meanwhile one of the decisions
that i mentioned
as well as keeping white's rook on the
fifth rank which looked risk-free
completely winning for white uh instead
magnus has given up his rook for the
black knight and now he's retreated his
bishop to this square which guards the
first rank so blackstroke cannot come
down to the first rank to check the
white king because the white bishop
guards any infiltration
so right now it's a bishop and knight
against a rook
normally the bishop knight should be
superior to the black rook but
temporarily the white king is far away
black does have a past pawn on the c
file black's king is very active
what do we think some saving chances
well i think there's a very important
idea that white has here i mean the only
danger for white
is black's pawn i i think the c pawn the
pass pawn we call it because when you're
in an ending you've got to try to throw
that down the board and i think white
has a very just simple way of guarding
that he can
drop his yeah we can put it on the board
drop his bishop back to stop that going
forwards
the pawn can't come forward if it's
supported by the king let's say now
then
i think you can just move your knight to
to really uh block block that from ever
happening your king the white king will
surely just come in now and slowly but
surely you'll
you win the game
i would have thought um i think it's
quite key as well on that line you show
simon uh sorry just for example okay he
jumped in with the knight first same
right yeah okay so uh if the bishop had
jumped it's nice that you can actually
take this uh take this pawn and you can
still come back and block uh any
potential checkmating ideas we normally
say give your king some breathing space
because you don't want to get checked uh
checkmated on the back rank but the
bishop can block magnus though he
doesn't want to go passive with his
bishop for example he doesn't want to
risk for example the black rook coming
and grabbing this lone pawn so he goes
the other way but same idea you
mentioned there simon and
very effective the white knight just
completely blocks the advance of black's
only hope the past pawn
and it's annoying you can't even bring a
rook in right now you can't bring a rook
in to attack pawns because this knight
jumps back with a fork
and uh winning the game
yeah and i think if magnus now just
improves his king and then you know
endings you should always look where you
have majority of pawns what side of the
board white has the majority of pawns on
the king side four
versus three so at some point you should
be able to create a past pawn at some
point that passport will probably become
a queen so it's quite a
looks pretty simple is winning plan to
be honest i mean uh long term i i don't
think there's anything even
you know that black can do because
you're stopping all blacks counter
playing yeah black's pawns are fractured
and uh i mean these pawns are these
pawns are isolated and uh knights are
fantastic against isolated pawns and
your plan in action simon just rerouting
the white king one more square and the
black rook will never break into the
white camp um it's important that the
black rook if it does come in it can be
completely neutralized by the white
bishop stepping back defense defending
sorry this one uh in the corner but also
attacking this weak black pawn
and it's just yeah as you mentioned
almost game over knight and bishop
together are worth six points the black
rock only worth five but it's not just
that there's two of them and that's
better than black's one piece the rook
i mean i think uh jordan's been quite
off form today i think it's fair to say
and i think the thing with players like
jordan
it's much harder he's very creative and
sometimes that can be you know dazzling
brilliancy but on other days if it's not
quite 100
it can be disastrous because he's always
trying to do something creative he's
always trying to think outside the box
and it's harder to play that way in the
long run so it's a lot of energy it's a
lot it's just the energy isn't it
because rather than just copying doing
things you're used to you're always
thinking of something unique
and yeah that just makes you know it's
harder to keep that tempo up
you know wait wait wait until he gets my
age it'd be impossible you know
you have to change his style slightly or
adapt to it yeah
it's it's quite funny actually on that
topic we um my chat is with shakira
mamajarov again not to spoil give too
many spoilers but uh he talks about that
and he says you know so many people said
to him hey you know you're getting older
why do you not just play boring chess
and he's like
i can't
it's not in my personality when i play
chess it has to be with the heart it has
to be the soul i have to ignite that
passion and um
yeah but um here you go you know we see
the downsides of playing in such a fiery
style and
magnus is in full control and simon you
did ask ask
the our twitter viewer our viewers are
saying you know what kind of mottos did
they have when they play chess
and uh tyler welch says my motto when
playing chess is stolen from thanos
i okay maybe david can do it because
dave is a big let's see
can we hear it in the voice
oh no yeah come on
[Laughter]
yeah if someone did that you'd be like
okay
i resigned i resigned yeah you are
inevitable try that next time david yeah
doesn't work out so well for him the
second time he says
no spoilers
yeah big marvel fan literally the
highlight of my song is going to be
watching the new thor
yeah
movies
yeah the mighty thor but uh this
position not looking so mighty for
jordan i'm looking forward to the new
top gun movie i think that's out soon
welcome to the
what is it
danger zone no i know it's not it's
something else
welcome to my way to the dangerous
highway that's where he went
i just i just freestyled my lyrics all
right i just i'm not i'll just make him
up you know call her that way
we had a horseshoe where we all were
saying welcome to the
people
i still haven't haven't seen the film
don't know the music so
it's very yeah yeah yeah it's very 80s i
feel like you know all 90s boise kind of
does it kind of age well though because
i often feel like these 80s films you
you take a look at them and you're like
you see
i think it ages very well so definitely
and uh talking of 80s 90s these two
players born in the 90s there
i mean it's only only going to be one
winner and that is magnus carlsen the
position has not improved at all for
black and look at those white pawns
they've started to push
um literally nothing for jordan to do i
wouldn't be surprised if he just gives
up hope soon
i mean it's just those pawns it's very
actually simple to win
there's white pawns i'm watching love it
your fate is sealed
that's not that's not thanos that's
someone else i'm just making it up you
know
your faces your demises in the stars
so you know i'm just trying to think of
what i'm going to say to my opponent
next time i play yeah yeah so yeah
and yeah there's simply nothing to do
here for jordan look at the clock times
as well how imbalanced is that
more than 10 minutes for magnus in a
easily winning position at this point
the white king can just continue
centralizing itself or even marching
towards the right side of the board
white's bishop and knight have
everything locked down
it's a complete control i mean
it's in my mind now that one word
inevitable but this position is
basically the definition of inevitable
black it just has to sit and wait and do
nothing i mean i think the only thing
that could go wrong is if white gets
greedy loses control
of of black's only past pawn so let's
say you grabbed a pawn now with check
um very greedy this is you wanna in
positions like this is so much more
important to keep control rather than
get greedy and if you did go for the
check black moves is king we can win
another pawn but you've lost control a
little bit now because the black pawn is
suddenly free
the white knight was controlling that
one but now
you know you don't want to allow any
counter play this is just key stop the
counter play don't put your piece on bad
squares like this night even if you can
win a pawn in the process and yeah as
you mentioned simon stop all counter
play but not just that
in the current position improve your
pieces and this white king is
destined to come in and start picking
off the remaining black pawns this is
where white has the advantage that's why
magnus is playing on that side when you
have a poor majority it makes sense to
play on that flank
there's no stopping that white king from
getting to its destination as well
because yes you can attack pawns but hey
the knight can actually step back to the
c4 square or
magnus just goes well i don't even need
to defend it that king is just gonna run
to chase and gobble up those pawns on
the right yep so white giving up this
pawn in the center to the black crook
but uh instead just going after these
pawns uh we might even see a trade here
but there's no way to keep this pawn
intact if you try and defend it with
your king then the white bishop sweeps
in and captures another pawn and yeah
it's uh actually close to a mating that
now for the black king this white pawn
is going to step forward sooner or later
it's uh
i can't say the word inevitable it's
getting close though
for a win for magnus wow with the white
pieces in a game where they have played
the queen's gambit decline i'm super
happy we did see that because it turns
out it is the second most popular
opening on the tour and i have another
fact about it so ty our stats genius
just um wrote me that magnus has played
five games with the black pieces in the
queen's gambit declined can you guess
what his score is
in those games where you have the black
pieces in that opening this season he
beat pragnanda in the queen's camp
declined last month
100
it's not 100 that's broken but it's 70
70 with black that is incredible yeah so
is he an expert in this opening yeah yes
from both sides white and black expert
in everything isn't he really yeah and
he's also expert in like those very
unusual variants of the queen's gambit
the client and he just simply knows how
to handle the positions and he knows
you know when to be patient
when to strike um i mean absolutely
fantastic player but in the queen's
camera declined he's like phenomenal
yeah he's phenomenal then i mean i
remember him beating nakamura on both
sides of that many many times i think
magnus one of the best patches of his
career in uh early 2019 he was just
every time on the white side of the
queen's camera declined he would just
smash his opponents off the board um
just it was just a joy to watch we
rarely talk about like which openings is
magnus the expert one he's the universal
player but uh this is the opening he is
the expert then
one of them yeah
he's so good at everything i mean this
is you know you can play i think he's a
real what people don't realize a real
student of the game so he he's done a
lot of work and he's got incredible
memories so he's able to recall
games from hundreds of years ago uh
exact positions which were played in
certain openings and you know adapt them
into his own play
and yeah it's it's just one of his big
strengths
opening books he's just pouring over
them all the time i mean this game is
not going to last much longer now white
is simply going to capture this black
pawn on the right side of the board
white's two pawns are unstoppable and at
the very least white can give up one of
his pieces the white or the white bishop
for black's pawn in the middle of the
board those two white pawns uh sorry on
this side they're just gonna march up
and win the game
it's a matter of time now done giving up
hope
yeah look at that two minutes for jordan
magnus still has 11 minutes left on the
clock what happened in this game was it
preparation that jordan didn't follow i
have a feeling jordan just mixed up his
opening move orders maybe he had an idea
in this opening but
that one moment we praised magnus maybe
for being brave grabbing a pawn
after that i mean jordan never got back
in the game simply he never recovered
um
maybe a slight opening disaster from
jordan but magnus's technique ever since
that one small slip in the opening
just been
just been
flawless
and now the white knight jumping just
attack the black rook but also to stop
black's pawn from marching forward that
white knight will keep the black pawn
under locking key and white pawns win
the game and i'm looking at the bar on
the bottom of the screen mishra
mamadiaro momodyarov is
is still world number five something
like that the bar all the way over to
mishra's side and we do have a result in
this game it is a win for magnus carlsen
the second win in a row horrible start
for jordan today he uh only has one
point out of those four for his games
but magnus will be
somewhere along the top